[Music]
welcome back to las vegas now eric
palacios and associates the sponsors of
this next segment join us to break down
what the penalties for a dui are and
some suggestions that he has for people
before getting behind the wheel take a
look
all right eric this is such a sad story
henry rugs iii is involved in this
horrible accident
he is over twice the legal limit and
doing an incredible speed more than 150
miles per hour in a residential area and
someone died as a result
what are the charges that he or someone
like him could face
in this situation
uh well the the worst charges that a
person can
face for killing someone is it while
driving a vehicle is vehicle
which carries uh
25 to life
the lower charge would be
dui causing
bodily harm or death and this carries
two to 20 years
in prison and then additional fines loss
of his license
uh and other penalties so as far as we
know so far those are the charges that
are being contemplated
and we'll see where it goes from there
so again the maximum he could face would
be what
that depending on what he's charged with
but with the current charges up to 20
years okay but those charges could be
increased
they could once the the prosecutor gets
all the details uh the
charges could be enhanced or they could
remain the same or they could be lower
dependent
all right
uh for someone who rolls the dice drives
when they shouldn't be driving and and
thankfully nobody gets hurt what kind of
charges do they face if they're caught
driving while intoxicated for a first
time dui uh if no one is injured then
you're looking at misdemeanor charges
then this would be uh from uh
two days up to ten days uh in jail uh
usually you'll at least spend the night
in jail and then you're looking at fines
between four hundred to a thousand
dollars to attend dui school a victim
impact panel uh you'll get your license
taken away for up to six months
and depending on the level of your uh
alcohol in your blood you might have
enhancements as well so even if no one
is injured it's still not a fun process
to go through so eric this is this is a
tragic example of how lives are on the
line
every time someone decides to
drive after they've been drinking
and then yet there are so many
alternatives especially nowadays with
uber and everything else what are things
you tell people to avoid driving under
the influence
well and we see a lot of commercials
about this lately how buzz driving is
drunk driving so uh even if you've just
had a few drinks
you can tell when you're you're impaired
you might still
be able to carry on a conversation you
might feel like you're in control but
you can tell when you're a little buzzed
and you've had too much so don't risk it
don't think oh i can make it i'm not
driving that far i'll drive slow or i'll
be extra careful uh if you've had more
than a few drinks
like you said there's uber there's lyft
there's calves you can call a friend
someone can give you a ride there's so
many alternatives now that there really
is no excuse for drinking and driving
for more information give eric palacios
and associates a call at
at
702-444-7777
we'll be right back